[Music]
a bizarre incident occurred in an
english city
it was later revealed the terrible
disaster had been caused by the c
virus a mutanogenic toxic created by the
he wanted me to [ __ ] switch on the
russians and i did do that
if you give us the names right now you
can uh double agent for us viper boy are
you okay
they've nothing on me they've nothing on
me what the [ __ ] listen can we meet up
very soon in a cinematic clandestine
fashion
standby all crew aqua team
suspect identified so the cops said if i
organized a meeting with the russians
they'd let me go back to my old
i didn't believe they'd let me go so i i
sent a body double well
what's the story i'm liking it put it
there
stefan was a good guy [ __ ] shame what
happened to him
okay i'm on the five sisters move on
shut them up [ __ ] off
shut them up shut the [ __ ] up come on
here we go here we go
gives the chips an island are you
staying around for a chunk or now if
you're not going to
fight
[Music]
mission accomplished good luck
you know mine's got no hands that is
london
if i knew i was going to be assassinated
by sani man i wouldn't send stefan
now he's gone god rest his soul i'll
have to live with that for the rest of
my life
back in the safety and comfort of my
home in mayo
[Music]
hello mr viperman you can't get away
from us
that easy you're coming back with me
to mother russia
[Music]
the russians got me over here they want
me to be a propaganda tool
i'm not going to be doing that okay no
way no how
and i mean yes they've got a lot of
strong military history that they want
everybody to see
but i mean that's not because they want
to strike fear into anyone's hearts
how are you getting that what's the
story
all right your mother
and i'd like it to say that the russian
vaccination is the only way
it's a really good job and i've been
told to stress this is really my opinion
i'm not under duress
expressions
oh
[Music]
brought to you by sputnik light how you
keeping tom
francis here just let you know i've been
kidnapped and forced to make propaganda
videos for sputnik over in russia i have
no wallet or way of getting home you
need to come over and help me tom please
bye
you